in the last video we discussed how the
portuguese began to really expand their
exploration around africa with the
invention of the caravel a fast new ship
that could sail into the wind and how
spain newly united with ferdinand and
isabella completed its campaign to expel
muslims from spain the rey conquista
in 1492 and began to look outward for an
opportunity to compete with portugal and
it was into that moment that they
received an interesting proposal from
this man here christopher columbus so
who was christopher columbus well he was
a navigator he was born around 1451 we
think
in genoa which is today in italy and
he
had sailed quite a bit in his life he
was also a voracious reader thanks to
the invention of the printing press back
in 1450
and one book that he read with great
interest was the account of marco polo
and his travels in china and columbus
dreamt of getting to china and they're
accessing riches
silk and spices
and maybe even converting people living
in asia to christianity
and teaming up with them
in a new crusade to expel muslims from
the middle east now there are two common
myths about columbus that i'd like to
dispel one of these is that columbus was
the first european
to discover the americas
in fact we know that around 1 000 ce
the vikings of norway
had colonized greenland and had explored
around
what is today canada
so you might be asking
okay well if the vikings
discovered america why aren't we talking
about the vikings in this video
and the short answer is
the viking settlement in the americas
did not last very long
less than a generation and it also
didn't really get well known outside of
norway so it didn't have the worldwide
impact on colonization that columbus's
voyage would have
the other myth about columbus is that he
was the lone visionary who knew that the
world was round
everybody else
thought that the world was flat and
columbus proved them wrong
in fact most learned people had known
that the world was round since the time
of the ancient greeks what they thought
instead was that the world was simply
too big they estimated that it was about
25 000 miles in circumference which is
pretty close to the truth and that even
if you could sail out here into the
ocean you would run out of supplies and
die long before you ever hit land
because they had no idea that the
americas were over here columbus however
had done some different calculations and
he thought that the circumference of the
world was only about
16 to 18 000 miles
so that the coast of japan was about 3
000 miles to the west of europe now he
was wrong but he got very lucky because
about 3 000 miles to the west of europe
he encountered
landfall he just didn't know that what
he found there wasn't china so columbus
has this dream and he kind of shops it
around the courts of europe looking for
royal patronage and first he tries the
portuguese because they are the reigning
leaders of navigation and they turn him
down saying his idea is too risky he
also tries france and england with
similar results finally he tries spain
and ferdinand and isabella agree that
they will stake him they give him three
ships
and a crew of 87 men
and in august
of 1492
he takes off makes a brief stop in the
canary islands and then turns west into
open waters and in october of 1492 he
made landfall and this is what he found
so he landed on the small island that he
named san salvador which is today in the
bahamas
and then he continued to explore around
the coast of cuba that he called juana
and then he ended up in the island that
he called hispaniola which is today the
island of haiti
and the dominican republic
and we'll talk more about who he met in
the new world in the next video